wo ist dein ding
[Musik]
alles in ordnung
bis die werke steht man ja blöde fragen
steht der mann mit dem besten abschluss
im gesamten ja ja so toll
tja das bedeutet ein ende meines
studiengangs ist in sicht denn studiums
erst beendet wenn du deine
studiengebühren ab bezahlt hast ja wenn
ich erst mal arbeitet wäre das kein
problem
könnt ihr euch an die fotos erinnern die
ich für die zeitschrift gemacht habe die
berufs porträts die redakteurin hat mir
schon einen job angeboten
ich weiß noch nicht denn wer angestellt
und du willst dich lieber selbstständig
machen
was bedeutet selbst dann nicht machen
wenn ich selbstständig arbeite dann bin
ich mein eigener chef und ich kann
entscheiden welche aufträge ich annehme
und welche nicht
aber es kann auch sein dass du gar keine
aufträge bekommst sowie bei people
ja das ist eben ein bisschen unsicher
aber jetzt muss ich halt nicht
entscheiden später
[Musik]